णमो अरिहंताणं णमो सिद्धाणं णमो आयरियाणं णमो उवज्झायाणं
णमो लोए सव्व साहूणं नमः समयसाराय
स्वानुभूत्या चकासते । चित्स्वभावाय भावाय
सर्वभावान्तरच्छिदे मंगलं भगवान वीरो,
मंगलं गौतमो गणी। मंगलं कुन्दकुन्दार्यो,
जैनधर्मोऽस्तु मंगलम्॥ सर्वमङ्गलमाङ्गल्यं
सर्वकल्याणकारकम। प्रधानं सर्वधर्माणां
जैनं जयति शासनम॥ द्वैतपुरुषोत्तमम्। ॐकारबिन्दुसंयुक्तं
नित्यं ध्यायन्ति योगिनः। कामदं मोक्षदं चैव
ॐकाराय नमो नमः
श्री द्रव्य दृष्टि प्रकाश. पूज्य निहालचंद जी सौगानीजी के आध्यात्मिक पत्र.
पत्र number 22. आजे 5मो अध्याय चंद्राय.
आज 5वाँ स्वाध्याय
चल रहा है। प्रश्न
ऐसा किया है कि किस प्रकार आत्मा
अपनी और पुरुषार्थ की वृद्धि करने का प्रयोग करता है?
जिस आत्मा को आत्मज्ञान हो गया है वो अब आगे क्या करता है, कैसे करता है
ताकि वो परमात्मा बने?
इसके प्रश्न में अपना विषय चल रहा है तो उसका केंद्र बिंदु। तो उसका केंद्र बिंदु
आगे बढ़ने का एकमात्र वही है।
अपना परमात्मा। बाहर में कोई परमात्मा है या सद्गुरु है
या साधर्मी लोग हैं या सत्संग है।
या ज्ञानी पुरुषों के शास्त्र हैं। या उनकी वाणी, tape, video है।
ये सब तो external force है।
अंतर में स्वयं अपने बल पे आगे बढ़ो। देव अपने बल पे आगे बढ़ना होता है।
मोक्ष मार्ग में कभी दूसरे के मार्ग पे बल पे आगे नहीं बढ़ना होता। जैसे
हमको स्वर्ग में जाना है तो हमको खुद को मरना है। तो ही हम जा सकते हैं।
इसी प्रकार से अगर हमको आगे बढ़ना है तो।
तो फिर हमारे हमारे आत्मा का ही शरण हमको लेना पड़ता है।
कैसा है वो आत्मा वो बात बताइए। कि अखंड ज्ञान घन। अखंड ज्ञानघन पुरुषाकार
शरीर कर्म भाव कर्म और blankness और शुद्ध पर्याय
सबसे भिन्न उससे भी गहराई में जानने देखने वाली जो
तत्व है सार वही मैं हूँ वही मेरा अस्तित्व है और उसमें
नज़र करते ही आनंद होता है।
उसमें नज़र करते ही आनंद की अनुभूति होती है
लेकिन वो आनंद की अनुभूति भी मेरे
से बाहर है मेरे में नहीं है। शुद्ध पराय का अस्तित्व भी उसमें गौण है।
ऐसी प्रथम यथार्थ श्रद्धा जब ही कही जाती है
कि ऐसी श्रद्धा के प्रसार के साथ ही लीनता का प्रथम आत्मानुभव होता है।
ऐसी ही वहां नज़र पड़ते ही अनुभव होता है पहली बार। लीनता का पुरुषार्थ
अथवा इसमें वृद्धि ये सब पर्याय के कारण है। इसी प्रकार से दोबारा तीसरी बार चौथी बार।
इस प्रकार से पूरा मेहनत करके पुरुषार्थ करके लीनता करना।
और फिर लीनता तो हो रही है लेकिन अभी time बढ़ता है अंदर का। कि पहले
देखा तो 1 second अंदर रहा। देखा एक second एक second अंदर रहा, बाद में 2
second बाद में 3 second ऐसा
time वृद्धिगत होता है।
तो लीनता की वृद्धि, लीनता और लीनता की वृद्धि दोनों में फर्क।
नजर वहां जाना वो लीनता। और वहां ज्यादा देर तक ठहरना
उसका नाम लीनता की वृद्धि। ये सब कार्य परमात्मा नहीं करता।
परमात्मा को वो कार्य करना नहीं। वो तो सिर्फ... वो तो सिर्फ अपने... वो
नज़र भी करना वो उसका काम नहीं है कि मैं मेरे को देखूँ ऐसा नहीं होता।
वो तो सिर्फ महसूस होना होता है। और महसूस करना भी उसका काम नहीं है।
महसूस करना भी अवस्था करेगी मैं नहीं करूँगा। परमात्मा
कुछ भी नहीं करता है वो निष्क्रिय तत्व है।
परमात्मा में मतलब मेरे में कुछ होने
नहीं होने का... कोई question नहीं। कोई question नहीं ये सब कार्य
लीनता का पुरुषार्थ और उसमें वृद्धि ये सब पर्याय के कार्य हैं मेरापना
मेरा अस्तित्वपना अथवा व्यापकपना तो केवल त्रिकाली
ज्ञानगंध अखंड चैतन्य में है ऐसी दृष्टि में
ऐसी नज़र करने से ऐसी ऐसा। ऐसी ऐसा मानने
से दृष्टि माने मानना इस प्रकार से मानने से
पर्याय का पुरुषार्थ
उसका सहज
स्वभाव है। ऐसे दुखी आदमी को
देखते हैं और चिल्लाता है, भीख मांगता है, रोता है,
तो ऐसा scene देख कर के हमको सुख का आनंद नहीं आता है।
हमको भी करुणा के या दया के ऐसे ही भाव आ जाते हैं उसको देखकर।
और सुखी आदमी को देखते हैं तो?
तो उसके आनंद आनंद का जैसा उसको कितना आनंद मिलता होगा उसका हमको
अंदर में feeling होती है। परमात्मा को देखें तो? परमात्मा को देखें
पर उसमें आनंद अपने आप होता है। आनंद लाने की चीज नहीं है। बस देखने से काम होता है।
मांगना नहीं पड़े, बिना मांगे मिले। Just आप देखो।
और आनंद हो जाता है। और सारी अशांति, डर, भय, कल्पना, भविष्य की चिंताएं,
भूतकाल के अफसोस सब खत्म 1 second के अंदर। नजर में ही कमाल है।
होत आसवा परिसभा। कृपा जी ने एक भक्ति लिखी है हिंदी में।
होत आसवा परिसभा। आसवा माने राग द्वेष। परिसभा माने... परिसभा माने
परि माने समस्त रूप से सभा माने त्याग होता है। नाश होता है।
होत आसवा परिसभा नहीं इनमें
संदेह है। इसमें कोई शंका की बात नहीं है कि राग द्वेष मिटते हैं।
मात्र दृष्टि की भूल है। भूल गए गते लेकिन क्या करें?
तुम्हारी नज़र में ही खोट है। जहाँ देखना चाहिए वहाँ देखते नहीं हो।
जहाँ नहीं देखना चाहिए वही नज़र में आता है। चाहते हैं तो हम सुखी होना।
लेकिन काम सारे दुखी होने के करते हैं। सुखी होने का ये उपाय है।
मोक्ष मार्ग में वृद्धि करने का, पुरुषार्थ की वृद्धि करने का ये उपाय है।
क्या उपाय है कि मैं सबसे
भिन्न परमात्मा हूँ। बस that's all
finish। अब अब क्या होगा ऐसा मानना। अब अब क्या होगा ऐसा मानने से?
कि जिस परिणति में ऐसा मानना हुआ,
उस परिणति को आनंद मिले बिना नहीं रहेगा।
सुखी होने का इतना आसान तरीका है। सुखी होने के लिए क्या करना?
कि मैं परमात्मा हूँ ऐसा मानना। तो सुखी हो जाओगे।
कहीं ऐसा तो नहीं है ना कि धोखा हो जाएगा? धोखा हो जाएगा।
हम राजा नहीं हो राजा माने तो फिर मज़ा आ जाएगी ऐसा थोड़ा है।
हम अभी बाहर में भीख मांगते हैं और फिर हम... तुम मानो तुम राजा हो।
अच्छा भई मान लेते हैं चलो। मानने में क्या जाता है? मान लो ना राजा हो।
सुखी होने में जब इतना आसान है तो मान लो। अच्छा भई चलो हादसे में राजा हो।
फिर भूख लगेगी तो भई खाना तो दो।
चाय में शक्कर नहीं है चाय
शक्कर तो डालो। शक्कर नहीं है चाहे शक्कर तो डालो हो गए राजा ऐसा नहीं चलता है
ये ये तरीका नहीं है मैं परमात्मा हूँ ऐसा मानने के लिए
उसको एक बार देख लेना पड़ेगा देख लो फिर कभी नहीं भूलोगे
एक बार देखना पड़ेगा और उसको एक बार देखने के लिए
क्या करना पड़ता है बहुत कुछ करना पड़ता है।
वो एक बार अपने परमात्मा को देखने के लिए बहुत कुछ करना पड़ता है।
सबसे पहले तो दुनिया में कुछ नहीं चाहिए मुझे सिवाय शांति के, वो पहले final कर लो।
मानने से राजी होने का है,
मानने से सुखी हो जाते हैं, लेकिन मानने में ही गड़बड़ है, जानने में तो कुछ नहीं है।
मानने में तकलीफ है। परमात्मा माने तो फिर मैं देवचंद भाई वो नहीं रहता है।
कि मेरा मकान नहीं रहता है, मेरा शरीर नहीं रहता है।
और मेरापना जहाँ जहाँ लगाया ना सब जगह निकल जाता है। वो जो
शरीर से भिन्न, कर्म से भिन्न, भाव कर्म से भिन्न, शुद्ध पराय से भिन्न,
जो जानने देखने वाला तत्व वो मैं हूँ। ऐसा जब आएगा,
तब फिर मैं शरीर वाला, मैं परिवार वाला, मैं किसी का भाई, मैं किसी का पिता,
मैं मनुष्य वो नहीं रहेगा। मानवुं ए तो मानवुं बराबर छे.
मानवामां बहु बधो छे. एटले धर्मनो base शुं छे? धर्मनो base छे सम्यक दर्शन.
सची मान्यता. सम्यक दर्शन.
सच्चां दर्शन होय, सची मान्यता होय, सच्चां श्रद्धा होय तो जीव दुःखी केम थाय?
लेकीन जीव दुःखी होता है. तकलीफ में है, ढेर सारी चिंताए है. चिंताएं हैं
इच्छाओं का अंत नहीं है और कोई इच्छा पूरी होती नहीं है और दुखी दुखी दुखी दुखी है
इसका कारण क्या है कि इसका vision गलत है इसकी मान्यता गलत है
जब इसका vision सही हो जाएगा मान्यता सही हो जाएगा इसका देखना सही हो जाएगा
और सही होगा कब जब वो मानेगा कि मैं परमात्मा हूँ तो समझना कि इसका vision सही हो गया।
एक बार अगर देख लिया और मान लिया कि मैं परमात्मा हूँ, खलास। फिर उसको
कितना भी करो दुखी नहीं कर सकते। कितना भी करो,
आंधी आए चाहे तूफान आए, वो दुखी नहीं हो सकता है।
वो permanent सुखी हो गया। जैसे छाछ में से मक्खन निकाल लेते हो,
बाद में मक्खन को
वापस मिला दो छाछ में। Impossible है, अब नहीं मिलेगा। Impossible है अब नहीं मिलेगा।
ऐसे एक बार अगर मान्यता बदल गई, finish।
फिर कोई फर्क नहीं पड़ता है।
फिर तो जितना पूर्व का कर्म बांधा है अज्ञान अवस्था में, उसका कर्जा चुकाने के
लिए हमको संसार में रहना है।
और अंदर की साधना करते-करते संसार में रह सकते हो।
जब साधना बढ़ जाएगी और काम-वापस कर्जा भी चुक जाएगा।
और यहाँ साधना बढ़ जाएगी। और यहाँ साधना बढ़ जाएगी। क्या होगा? परमात्मा बन जाएगा।
कौन बनेगा परमात्मा? जो पहले से ही परमात्मा है।
वो ये मानते-मानते कि मैं परमात्मा हूँ, मैं परमात्मा हूँ।
ऐसा मानते-मानते बार-बार उसको देखते-देखते वो परमात्मा। बन जाएगा।
परमात्मा बनने का कोई दूसरा पूछा ना कि कैसे आगे बढ़ें? पूछा ना कि कैसे आगे बढ़े?
आत्मा का अनुभव होने के बाद आगे कैसे बढ़े? यही तरीका और कोई तरीका नहीं है।
केवल त्रिकालिक ज्ञानघन अखंड चैतन्य मैं हूँ, इस दृष्टि में
पर्याय का फुर्सत सहज स्वभाव है। ऐसी नज़र होते ही
पर्याय में आनंद होना, लीनता होना, उसमें वृद्धि होना,
राग द्वेष कम होते जाना, ये
सब automatic है। वो... ये सब automatic है वो आपको करना नहीं है।
कि नहीं क्रोध बहुत आता है क्रोध को खत्म कर देना है। तो नहीं तुम नहीं कर सकते।
फिर कैसे कम होगा? आप परमात्मा में ऐसी दृष्टि करो अपने आप
कम हो जाएगा। क्रोध को खत्म नहीं करना है गलत भाव को मिटाना नहीं है।
आप परमात्मा में ऐसा नजर करो
सब मिट जाएगा अपने आप। जो काम अपने आप होता है।
उसको दुखी हो करके क्यों करते हो?
तो नहीं दुकान छोड़े तो ही होता है। दुकान छोड़ने की जरूरत दुकान जाओ
लेकिन अवलोकन करो दुकान की रुचि खत्म हो जाएगी। पहले क्या होता है?
दुकान नहीं छुट्टी है पहले। पहले क्या होता है? कमाने की जो रुचि है,
कि दुकान मेरी है ऐसी जो रुचि है, और आग्रह है कि 10 बजे खोलना ही है,
पहले वो खत्म होता है। नहीं तो ग्राहक भाग जाएंगे और नुकसान हो जाएगा। नुकसान हो
जाएगा ना। भाग गए तो भाग गए।
वो कमाने की जो लालच, ग्राहक को संभालने की लालच, सेवा करने की लालच,
जंजाल बढ़ाने की लालच, वो खत्म पहले होती है।
दुकान नहीं है, दुकान तो अभी भी जाना पड़ता है।
और बिल्कुल लालच नहीं होगी कमाने की तो भी जब तक आपको दुकान के साथ लेना-देना है,
संबंध है, जाना ही पड़ेगा।
नहीं नहीं जाऊंगा। तुम्हारे हाथ में नहीं है नहीं जाना।
जाना ही पड़ेगा। नहीं नहीं मैं
car में नहीं बैठूंगा। नहीं तुझे बैठना पड़ेगा। ऐसा कैसे हो?
पैदल कैसे चलोगे तुम? नहीं बैठना ही पड़ेगा car
में। नहीं नहीं मैं त्यागी हूँ। त्यागी हो तो क्या हो गया? तुम अंदर में त्याग करो।
बाहर में तुझे
बैठना ही पड़ेगा। किसी
को ना ग्रहण कर सकते हैं ना छोड़ सकते हैं। समय के पहले ना कोई छोटा है, समय
के पहले ना कुछ। समय के
पहले ना कुछ ग्रहण होता है। ये ऐसा परमात्मा
है कि जाने देखे सब कुछ लेकिन करे धरे कुछ भी नहीं।
सूके घास के तिनके के दो टुकड़े करने की हमारे में ताक़त नहीं है,
ये ज्ञानियों के वचन हैं।
जैनों के भगवान हेराफेरी नहीं करते क्योंकि कर नहीं सकते।
जैनों के भगवान किसी को सुखी दुखी नहीं कर सकते क्योंकि कर नहीं सकते।
कि वो... कि वो भक्त हो तो उसको कृपा करके उसको ऊंची seat देना।
और जो गाली देने वाला है उसको मारना डंडा लेकर के। जैनों के भगवान ऐसा काम नहीं करते।
जैनों के भगवान ऐसे होते हैं। और पहले वो हम जैसे थे।
फिर आत्मा का अनुभव हुआ गुरु की कृपा और मार्गदर्शन से।
तब से वो धीरे-धीरे आत्मा में लीन होते होते होते
अपने परमात्मा का दर्शन, पूजा, भक्ति सब करते करते करते करते... करते हैं।
सभी प्रकार के राग द्वेष को धीरे-धीरे करके मिटा करके
आज वो वो position में हैं। कि उनकी नज़र आत्मा से हटती ही नहीं है।
और कितना सुख है?
जिसकी कोई सीमा नहीं है उतना सुख। परिपूर्ण शांति है।
उनको किसी की पूजा भक्ति
करने की ज़रूरत नहीं पड़ती है शास्त्र पढ़ने
की ज़रूरत नहीं पड़ती है जैनों के परमेश्वरों को।
किसी की आरती उतारना नहीं है किसी...
किसी की आरती उतारना नहीं है, किसी का भला करना नहीं है, किसी का बुरा करना नहीं है।
अपने में से बाहर निकले तो
करे ना, अपने में से बाहर ही नहीं निकलते।
अपने घर में रहते हैं और बहुत मजे में रहते हैं। क्या?
कितने volt का current है?
अंदर में? 1000 volt का नहीं, 440 का तो बात ही छोड़ो।
घर में 250 होता है, किसी आदमी battery में 440 होता है।
बड़ी factory में 10,000 volt रहता है। Factory में 10,000 volt रहता है। काहे
से छुए तो खत्म मामला।
लेकिन यहाँ तो अंदर में कितना बड़ा boundary है। अनंत
अनंत voltage है अनंत जिसका अंत नहीं है। बाहर कैसे निकलेंगे?
और वो voltage तो डराता है खून चूस लेता है। और ये
ये voltage कैसा है कि छुए तो निकलना नहीं बाहर। मजा आती है।
आनंद का voltage है ये
बिजली का voltage नहीं। Voltage है ये, बिजली का voltage नहीं है, आनंद का voltage।
अनंत voltage है। इसमें अगर प्रवेश कर गए, तो बाहर कभी निकलोगे नहीं।
निकलना चाहो तो भी नहीं निकल सकते।
ऐसा होता है। इस दृष्टि में
पर्याय का पुरुषार्थ सहज स्वभाव है, अपने परमात्मा की दृष्टि करना।
अगर ये हो गया हासिल, फिर आप फिकर छोड़ दो कैसे आगे बढ़ना है।
अब वो question मत करो कैसे आगे बढ़ो।
यही है बार-बार यही सब। पर्याय अपेक्षा पुरुषार्थ हुआ
वृद्धि हुई उसने पुरुषार्थ किया।
उसने व्रत तप लिए। उसने घर बार त्यागे। उसने कपड़े त्यागे
जंगल में चले गए साधना की आत्मा की। श्रेणी लगाई
केवल ज्ञान प्राप्त किया। सिद्ध भगवान बने ये सब। भगवान बने
ये सब बाहर से दिखता है वो कहने में आता है अंदर में उन्होंने एक ही काम किया
कौन सा काम किया है? मैं परमात्मा हूँ ऐसी दृष्टि की।
महावीर स्वामी ने 12.5 साल तक जंगल में ध्यान किया था
कैसे ध्यान किया? मांस
मदिरा का उपवास किया था।
और चंदन माला के पास से वो लेके आया ना खाने के लिए क्या?
अड़द के दाने क्या थे? के दाने क्या था? वो सब किया था। वो सब बाहर से देखा हमने।
अंदर में एक ही काम किया।
अंदर में उन्होंने अपने परमात्मा की दृष्टि से...
भूखा रहने से आगे नहीं बढ़ेगा तो
फिर नरक में तो खाने को ही नहीं मिलता है 10,000 साल तक minimum।
Minimum आयु से 10,000 और एक दाना नहीं मिलता है खाने को।
और भूख इतनी लगती है कि सारा अनाज खा जावे इतनी भूख लगती है। आ जावे
इतनी भूख लगती। अगर वो यहाँ आ जाए तो अपने को खाना ना देवे वो पूरा खा लेवे खुद ही।
यहाँ अपने को ही खा जाए ज्यादा वो गड़बड़ करे। इतनी भूख लगती।
वो पकाने की जरूरत नहीं
कच्चा ही खाए दबा लेवे। इतनी भूख रहती है। लेकिन मिलता नहीं है दाना भी नहीं मिलता है।
लेकिन धर्म नहीं होता है।
खाना छोड़ने से धर्म थोड़ा है। महावीर
स्वामी ने मांस सेवन का उपवास किया ना ऐसा। ने मांस सेवन का
उपवास किया, ऐसा अभिग्रह धारण किया।
वो उसका बाहर का रूप है, अंदर का रूप नहीं। अंदर में उन्होंने ये काम किया था।
अपने परमात्मा की दृष्टि की थी। तो व्रत,
तप, साधना सब बाहर में अपने आप होते गए।
ये पर्याय का स्वभाव है। ये कहने में आएगा कि Mahavir Swami ने ऐसा किया, वैसा किया।
लेकिन वो पर्याय की दृष्टि से। कहने में वैसा आएगा, लेकिन अंदर से देखा जाए तो
वो भगवान कैसे बने? कैसे बने? भगवान ऐसे बने।
मैं परमात्मा हूँ ऐसी दृष्टि लगाने से परमात्मा बने।
यथार्थ में तो अभ्यास शुरू करना है। यथार्थ में तो वास्तव में तो
पुष्ट अस्तित्व पाने की अखंड दृष्टि के बल पर पर्यायों का क्रम
सहज ही अखंड की ओर बढ़ता रहता है। अपना एक जो अंदर में
जो जहाँ नज़र करना... जो अंदर में जो जहाँ नज़र करनी है उसको बराबर समझ लो।
उसका target बनाओ। और कहीं नहीं जाकर के वहाँ ही रुकना है, उसको ही देखना है।
ऐसा एक fix कर दो।
कि लफड़े में मत जाओ किधर। इसने ऐसा क्यों किया वैसा क्यों किया,
सर मत खाओ। सीधा सुखी होना है ना? हाँ सुखी होना है। सीधा एक
target पकड़ लो। दृष्टि का विषय क्या?
किससे है क्या? किसको हम देखना है ताकी शांति मिले? वो कहां है? हुं कोण छुं?
क्यांथी थयो? शुं स्वरूप छे मारुं खरुं? कोना संबंधे
वळगणा छे? राखुं के ए परिहरुं?
एना विचार विवेकपूर्वक शांत भावे जो कर्या
तो सर्व आत्मिक ज्ञानना... सर्व आत्मिक ज्ञान ना सिद्धांत तत्व अनुभव।
रे आत्म तारो आत्म तारो शीघ्र हेने ओड़खो।
सर्वात्म समदृष्टि देव आगछल ने हृदयेल।
जिसको अपने आत्मा से प्यार है उसको सारी दुनिया के सभी आत्माओं से प्यार है।
किसी से राग द्वेष नहीं
सब मेरे जैसे आत्मा हैं। कोई जैन नहीं कोई अजैन नहीं कोई स्त्री नहीं। कोई जैन नहीं,
कोई अजैन नहीं, कोई स्त्री नहीं, कोई पुरुष नहीं।
कोई पामर नहीं, कोई परमात्मन नहीं, सब बराबर equal।
कोई ऊँचा नहीं, कोई नीचा नहीं, कोई अमीर नहीं, कोई गरीब नहीं, वो तो
सब अवस्थाओं का फर्क है।
कोई तरंग ऊँची है, कोई नीची है। वो सब फर्क किसमें है? अवस्थाओं में।
किसी का स्वभाव कैसा, किसी का स्वभाव कैसा।
किसी का atmosphere कैसा, किसी
का कैसा। किसी की बोली कैसी। ये सब पड़ा है। ये सब पर्यायों का खेल है।
जिसको अपने आत्मा का दर्शन हुआ उसको सभी में
एक ही जैसा आत्मा दिखता है, मेरे जैसा आत्मा है सब।
गड़बड़ करते हैं।
तो वो मेरा देखने का विषय नहीं है। मैं जब मेरी पर्याय को भी नहीं देखता हूँ,
मैं दूसरों की पर्याय को क्या देखूँगा? मुझे शांति
चाहिए तो मुझे मेरी पर्याय को भी नहीं देखना है कि कैसी चल रही है। मेरी
पर्याय को भी नहीं देखना है
कि कैसी चल रही है, तरण कैसे उठ रही है।
उपयोग बाहर है कि अंदर है वो मेरे को नहीं देखना है।
उपयोग बाहर है कि अंदर है वो वो देखना वो पर्याय को देखना।
उसका कोई इतना महत्व नहीं है। महत्व इस चीज का है
कि इन पर्यायों के पीछे जो परमात्मा है उधर नजर है या नहीं है।
अगर वहां नजर है तो
आपकी साधना बराबर चल रही है। वहाँ नज़र है तो आपकी साधना बराबर चल रही है।
वृद्धिगत है। तो जहाँ अपनी अवस्थाओं को भी नहीं देखना है।
वहाँ उसने ऐसा क्यों कहा,
उसने ऐसा बर्ताव क्यों किया, उसने ऐसा क्यों किया, ये तो कहाँ है?
ये तो boundary के बाहर चले गए।
पीछे से राग, उससे द्वेष, ये तो बहुत खराब है भाई। ये साधना कहाँ है?
यथार्थ साधना ऐसी नहीं होती है। यथार्थ में तो सही में अगर साधना करना है।
पुष्ट अस्तित्व बनेगी शरीर से, कर्म से, भाव कर्म से और उसके से भी गहराई में।
जो शुद्ध तत्व, चैतन्य तत्व है। यही मैं हूँ ऐसा अस्तित्व की दृष्टि,
कैसी दृष्टि? अखंड दृष्टि। टुकड़े-टुकड़े वाली नहीं, आवे-जावे ऐसी नहीं,
continuous धारा चलनी। अखंड दृष्टि और इसका... अखंड दृष्टि
और इसका जो बल उत्पन्न होता है अखंड दृष्टि
अखंड दृष्टि के बल पर ऐसा करने से
इसके बल से क्या होता है कि जो ये अवस्था है
इसके बल पर जो अवस्था है
उसका क्रम step by step एक के बाद। Step by step एक के बाद और अवस्था एक के
एक के बाद एक। क्योंकि कोई भी अवस्था एक second एक समय से ज्यादा टिकती नहीं है।
आई गई, दूसरी आई गई, तीसरी आई गई। ऐसे अवस्थाओं का क्रम होता है।
ये अवस्थाओं का क्रम, पर्यायों का क्रम सहज ही बिना प्रयत्न
अखंड की ओर बढ़ते रहता है। सबका controlling कहाँ है?
और दृष्टि कौन सी? वो दृष्टि कौन सी? मैं परमात्मा हूँ।
ये मैं परमात्मा हूँ वाली जो दृष्टि है वो controlling है।
उसको अगर आपने control कर लिया, अपने वश में कर लिया परमात्मा को,
तो बाद में जो भी होने वाला है अवस्थाओं में,
जो विकास होने वाला है, जो क्रमिक विकास होने वाला है,
जो अशुद्धता खत्म होने और शुद्धता होने वाली है, वो automatic है।
उसकी फिक्र आपको नहीं करना। कब बनूँगा परमात्मा? कब मुनि
बनूँगा? कब मुनि बनूँगा वो फिक्र तुमको करने की ज़रूरत नहीं है।
नहीं कब ये राग द्वेष छूटेंगे वो फिक्र तुझे करने की ज़रूरत नहीं है।
नहीं लेकिन अभी भी ऐसा तो हो रहा है। अभी भी ये गलतियाँ तो हो रही हैं।
उसकी फिक्र तुम मत करो। क्योंकि उसकी फिक्र करने जाओगे
तो नज़र यहाँ से हट जाएगी कहाँ से? कि मैं परमात्मा हूँ।
नहीं कब मैं आगे बढ़ूँगा? वही वही इतने साल से। वही वही इतने साल से
आ रहा हूँ वही वही। क्या
आगे नहीं बढ़ रहा हूँ मैं आगे नहीं बढ़ रहा हूँ।
आगे नहीं बढ़ रहा हूँ मैं। फिकर क्यों करते हो
आगे नहीं बढ़ रहा हूँ। तुम्हारी नज़र
अगर परमात्मा हूँ ऐसी रहेगी तुम अपने आप आगे बढ़ोगे। आगे बढ़ना क्या पीछे
बढ़ना क्या अगर ऐसी दृष्टि है तो। सबसे बढ़ना क्या अगर ऐसी दृष्टि है तो? परमात्मा
ना आगे है ना पीछे है।
ना छोटा है ना बड़ा है, परमात्मा तो जैसा है वैसा है। एक
धर्मदास सुदना जी का मेरे पास हाथ से लिखा हुआ है पुस्तक, अभी मेरे पास पुस्तक नहीं
लेकिन एक copy मिली थी तो मैंने अपने हाथ से लिखा है। मेरे को
याद नहीं है, उतना लंबा लंबा लिखता है आत्मा के बारे में।
कि वो पढ़ोगे तो हंसी आएगी। ना ऊपर है ना
नीचे हो ना आदि में हो। ना ऊपर हूँ ना नीचे हूँ ना आदि
में हूँ ना मध्य में हूँ ना अंत में हूँ।
वो गजब की शैली है। आत्मा का वर्णन करने की शैली जो है
वो पुस्तक का नाम है स्वात्मानुभव मनन। और धर्मदास सुदक ने अपनी
एक किताब लिखी है। तो उसके जो अंश हैं वो धुंधली हिंदी भाषा में हैं।
और वो book नहीं मिलती थी तो मैंने एक मैंने वो लेकर के मेरे हाथ से लिखा है।
मैं समझता हूँ 25-30 पन्ने मैंने लिख दिए हैं। लिख दिया है।
शायद ज्यादा भी लिखा होगा वो आत्म अनुभव
वर्णन में। कि ना मैं जैन हूँ,
ना दिगंबर हूँ, ना शैतंबर हूँ, ना वेदांती हूँ, ना मनुष्य हूँ।
मैं तो... ऐसो शुद्धात्मा की जगह भी इतना लंबा लंबा नाम लिखा है आत्मा का।
और फिर भी बोला ये सब... और फिर भी बोला ये शब्द जो है ना ये वो मैं नहीं।
आत्मा शब्द वो मैं नहीं।
उसके आदि में मैं नहीं, उसके मध्य में मैं नहीं, उसके अंत में मैं नहीं।
और आखिरी में मैं तो जो हूँ सो हूँ। इतना लंबा लिखने के बाद क्या लिखा?
मैं तो जो हूँ सो हूँ।
वचन से पार, इंद्रियों से पार, मन से
पार, पर्यायों से पार। जो शुद्ध तत्व है वो भी शब्द है, वो उसमें मज़ा
नहीं आती है, शब्द के बिना...
उसमें मज़ा नहीं आती है शब्द के बिना।
ऐसा लिखा है।
मैं गजब लिखा है मैं अभी कल देखूंगा घर में। वो book निकल आएगी तो बताऊंगा मैं।
कैसा लिखा है।
कि उसको कोई नाम नहीं दे सकते परमात्मा कैसा है तो
उसको कोई नाम नहीं दे सकते। उसका रूप क्या
उसका रंग क्या उसका color क्या उसका वजन कितना?
ये 3.5 kilo नहीं होता है। क्या?
वो ठिंगड़ा लंबा टूका। ना मोटा। ना मोटा पतला ऐसा नहीं होता।
कोई गजब है। ऐसा परमात्मा बोले उसकी दृष्टि होगी ना।
तो कैसे आगे बढ़ना चिंता करने की जरूरत नहीं। कैसे राग द्वेष मिटेंगे चिंता मत करो।
कब भगवान बनेंगे कब मुनि बनेंगे चिंता करने की कोई जरूरत नहीं।
कि मैं क्या करूं फिर? ये दृष्टि कर कि मैं परमात्मा। बस बाकी सब भूल जाए। ये सब
भूल जाए। इसमें बहुत बड़ा कमाल है, ये controlling power ये है।
सब कुछ है, petrol है, गाड़ी तैयार है, नई गाड़ी ली है, first class driving
running बन रही है, लेकिन driver नहीं है, क्या करोगे?
तो कैसे चलेगी गाड़ी? अब आप driving seat पे बैठ जाओ कि मैं परमात्मा हूँ,
आप देखो गाड़ी कैसे चलती है।
अब कोई problem नहीं है, लेकिन यहीं गड़बड़ करते हैं।
हम क्या करते हैं, राग द्वेष को मिटाने
जाते हैं। अशांति को मिटाने... अशांति को मिटाना चाहते हैं,
शांति लाना चाहते हैं। अपने progress करना चाहते हैं, पर जो चाह, जहाँ चाह है ना,
वहाँ आग है। हे जीव क्या इच्छत हवे,
है इच्छा दुख मूल,
जब इच्छा का नाश तब मिटे अनादि रोग।
निकारो तो कृपा उड़ेगा।
देखो क्या जबरदस्त लिया है। कि मुझे आत्मा में दृष्टि करनी है,
ध्यान लगाना है,
वो बात भी नहीं करना। उसमें भी गड़बड़ हो जाएगी। वो बात भी नहीं आनी।
सिर्फ मैं परमात्मा हूँ ऐसा मानना है बस इतने में पूरा आ गया।
वृद्धि कैसे होगी हम परमात्मा कैसे बनेंगे कि मानो। कि मैं परमात्मा हूँ।
और जब मानोगे तो कुछ करने डरने को रहता नहीं। देखो 680... देखो 680 number
first sentence
जेनी मोक्ष सिवाय कोई पण वस्तुनी ईच्छा के स्पृहा नहोती ए base उठाया
आत्मज्ञान होने का कारण मूळ base क्यां
तो मुजे कुछ नहीं मुजे तो सिर्फ शांति चाहीए मुजे मुक्ति चाहीए
मुजे दुःख तकलीफ कुछ नहीं चाहीए अंश मात्र भी नहीं चाहीए के
नहीं नहीं आपको 99% शांति देंगे. 99% शांति देंगे, 1% थोड़ा दुख देंगे।
नहीं, मेरे को 100% चाहिए। नहीं, थोड़ा adjust करो तो, नहीं, हम adjust नहीं करना। इस
मामले में हम adjust करना नहीं
चाहते। 100% बोलो तो 100%। 99.99% मुझे नहीं चाहिए। 100% ही
चाहिए।
जिसकी मोक्ष सिवाय कोई पनि वस्तुनि इच्छा के स्पृहा नहीं थी। मोक्ष माने क्या?
सारे दुखों का अंत,
सारी चिंताओं का अंत, कात्मक। और कौन? कात्मा। सारे राग द्वेष खत्म।
और पूर्ण शांति। थोड़ी शांति नहीं, पूर्ण शांति। इसका नाम मोक्ष।
कोई चाहिए और कुछ नहीं चाहिए।
दूसरी कोई चीज मुफ्त में भी नहीं चाहिए। नहीं बनना है मुझे इंद्र
स्वर्ग का। नहीं चाहिए मुझे राज। नहीं चाहिए मुझे दुनिया।
मुझे तो यही चाहिए। ये मेरी वेद था।
यहाँ से शुरू हुई यात्रा। और... और ऐसी चाहना के कारण सद्गुरु मिले, सद्गुरु
ने बताया कि तू परमात्मा हो।
और फिर हमने कोशिश की परमात्मा को देखने की। और जैसा उन्होंने बताया इस प्रकार से
कोशिश की, नहीं हुआ तो भक्ति भाव में आए। संसार में नहीं चले गए, भक्ति भाव में आए।
और भक्ति भाव से अंदर की सफाई पूरी हो गई।
फिर ज्ञानी पुरुष ने कहा ऐसे हमको अपने आप... आलीभूत ने कहा ऐसे हमको अपने
आत्मा की दृष्टि भी हुई।
और अब तो मज़ा आती है जब चाहे तब अंदर आत्मा में रहते हैं।
यहाँ तक की यात्रा। सिर्फ शांति चाहिए यहाँ से लेकर के यात्रा शुरू हुई और अब
अखंड स्वरूप में रमणता थी। अब मैं क्या हो गया है?
कि उस भावना से सद्गुरु मिले सद्गुरु का उपदेश सुना भक्ति पूर्वक उनकी आज्ञा उठाई
और अपने में दृष्टि की और अपने
में परमात्मा हूँ ऐसा देख लिया।
अने आपणे में परमात्मा होउं एसा देख लिया. अने देखने के बाद वाही रहा.
अखंड स्वरूपमां वास थवाथी, भ्रमणता थवाथी. क्या result आया?
मोक्षनी ईच्छा पण निवृत थई गई छे. आ पूछो उसको आत्मा
आत्मा के दर्शन हो गया ने पूछो. नहीं मोक्ष जाना है? नहीं मुजे नहीं जाना है.
नहीं आत्मा में उपयोग लगाना है?
मुजे नहीं लगा. बहार से उपयोग हटाना है? नहीं मुजे नहीं लगा. तो हटाना है.
नहीं मुजे नहीं हटाना. अब कोई ईच्छा नहीं रही. तो समजना के
आपकी साधना बिलकुल perfect है.
अखंड स्वरूपमां रमणता थवाथी मोक्षनी ईच्छा पण निवृत्त थई छे. तेने हे नाथ,
तुं तृष्टमान थईने पण बीजुं शुं आपवानुं?
जगतमां मुक्ति से बढके तो कोई चीज नहीं है और मुक्ति
नहीं चाहीए. क्योकी मुक्ति से बढिया कोई मिल गया है. मुक्ति क्युं
नहीं चाहीए? मुक्ति क्यों नहीं चाहिए?
क्योंकि मुक्ति से भी बढ़िया चीज़ कोई उसको मिल गई है। कौन सी चीज़ मिल गई उसको?
मैं ही स्वयं परमात्मा हूँ वो
मिल गया उसको। तो जिसको परमात्मा के दर्शन होते हैं वो
भीख मांगे? बाहर में? बाहर में भीख मांगने
का तो...
बाहर में भीख मांगने का तो सवाल ही नहीं वो
मोक्ष देवे तो भी बोले कि नहीं चाहिए मुझे मोक्ष जाओ।
भाई क्यों नहीं चाहिए? मुझे मिल गया मोक्ष।
कैसे मिला? कि मैं परमात्मा हूँ मुझे बंधन था ही कब? जब मोक्ष देने आए हो।
वो बंधन था वो अवस्था में था।
और दृष्टि मेरी परमात्मा में रहने से मुझे अशांति नहीं है तो मैं किससे छूटूँ अब?
अशांति से छूटना और शांति पाना उसका नाम मोक्ष है।
लेकिन मुझे अशांति हो तो ना। मुझे कोई अशांति नहीं है। क्यों अशांति नहीं
है? मुझे वो वो चीज़ मिल गई है जिसके लिए मैं अनंत काल से भटका।
मैं स्वयं परमात्मा हूँ, ऐसे मुझे बान हो गया है।
और ये चीज़ कभी मिटने वाली नहीं है, कभी कोई छीनने वाला नहीं है। क्यों?
क्योंकि यही मेरा अस्तित्व है।
दो चीज़ होती है तो खींच के लेते हो, लेकिन दो चीज़ नहीं। कैसे लेके जाओगे अभी आप?
परमात्मा को मेरे से अलग कैसे करोगे जबकि मैं ही स्वयं परमात्मा हूँ?
शक्कर में से मिठास निकाल दो चलो। अग्नि में से उष्णता निकाल दो।
कैसे बन सकता है? पानी में से शीतलता निकालो। कैसे बन सकता है?
ऐसे मैं हूँ मेरे
में से परमात्मा को निकाल दो या परमात्मा को डालो बाहर से। Impossible है।
फिर आप मुझे कुछ नहीं।
फिर अब मुझे कुछ नहीं चाहिए। क्योंकि
मैं परमात्मा हूँ तो मैं पूर्ण शांति में हूँ। अब मुझे शांति
नहीं चाहिए। इतना बड़ा काम होता है।
सम्यक दर्शन माने क्या समझते हो? गुरुदेव बोलते हैं सही बोलते हैं।
करोड़ अनंत अनंत करोड़ अरब रुपये का कर्जा चुका दिया। आत्मा का अनुभव हुआ तो क्या हुआ?
पहले अनंत शब्द फिर अनंत से तो
कोई value नहीं है ना अनंत की तो। उसने क्या किया? अनंत के तो उसने
क्या किया करोड़ करोड़ अरब अरब रुपया।
रुपये की value है।
अनंत अनंत करोड़ करोड़ अरब अरब रुपये का कर्जा चुका दिया।
अपने आत्मा का अनुभव किया। अच्छा?
तो कुछ बाकी रह गया है कि हाँ बाकी तो रह गया है। कल परमात्मा नहीं बना है ना।
कितना बाकी रहा? आधे रुपये का कर्जा बाकी रहा।
ये शब्द हैं गुरुदेव के। ये कोई छोटी मोटी सिद्धि नहीं है।
आत्मा का अनुभव करना,
मैं परमात्मा हूँ ऐसा अनुभव करना,
ये कोई छोटी मोटी बात नहीं है, ये बहुत बड़ी
बात है। लेकिन क्या है ये दुनिया वाले,
अपनी खुशी जाहिर करें तो जीने नहीं देते, बेकार के पथरे मारते हैं। इसलिए छुपा के रखना
अपने परमात्मा को।
क्या? क्या? बाकी हम ऐसे हैं। जिसको मिल गया वो कैसे है?
इस दुनिया में मेरे से बढ़कर कोई नहीं है ऐसा मानते हैं। वो उसको आत्मज्ञान होता है।
कि नहीं भगवान मेरे से ऊँचे हैं और मैं थोड़ा नीचे हूँ, मैं चौथे गुणस्थान में हूँ।
भगवान कौन से गुणस्थान में हैं? तेरहवें गुणस्थान में।
और सिद्ध भगवान? चौदह गुणस्थान के पार, वो मेरे से ज़्यादा बढ़के
अच्छे हैं। Impossible, मेरे से बढ़िया। Impossible
मेरे से बढ़िया दुनिया में कोई नहीं है दूसरा।
तो समझना कि उसको आत्मा का अनुभव हुआ है। कि नहीं मेरे से बढ़कर तो मुनिराज है।
मेरे से बढ़कर तो मेरे गुरु है। नहीं impossible है। बन ही नहीं सकता।
इस दुनिया में मेरे से बढ़कर कोई हो ही नहीं सकता।
तो ये समझना कि उसको आत्मा का अनुभव हो गया है। वो एक line
दोहराया हे नाथ। हे नाथ। हे नाथ तू... एने तू तुष्ट मन थईने पण बीजे शुं आपवानो?
तुष्ट मन राजी थई। अगर तू प्रसन्न नहीं होगे तो तुम क्या दे सकते हो? इससे बढ़िया
मुक्ति तो चाहिए नहीं। इससे बढ़िया तुम क्या दोगे? तेरी हैसियत क्या है?
और परमात्मा को अपुन देवे? हमारी क्या औकात? किसी की क्या औकात
कि परमात्मा को कुछ gift देवे? तो परमात्मा लेवे?
क्या अपना कोई relative थगा भाई क्यों ना हो करोड़पति अब्जापति हो क्या
उसको जाकर के ₹10 की fountain pen देओ birthday के दिन gift
क्या क्या value रखेगा वो ₹10 की ball pen वो gift में देगा
और अगर ले भी लिया अगर अपने को बुरा नहीं लगेगा लेकिन उसके नज़र में क्या value है।
क्या उसके fountain pen में ही diamond लगा हुआ है ₹1,00,000 का? और
सोने की ball pen है
उसके पास तो। और Mercedes में घूमता है।
तेरे जैसा कोई furniture नहीं है road पे रहने वाला।
तो ऐसा उसकी कोई value नहीं है फिर वो
deal को तकलीफ नहीं हो इसलिए ले लेते हैं लेकिन वो क्या करते हैं
ले लेते हैं रख देते हैं किसी को gift देने में काम आएगा। क्या? क्या?
कोई दिल को नहीं दुखाते हैं बाकी उसके नजर में उसकी कोई value नहीं
है। ऐसे जिसको परमात्मा मिल गया है परमात्मा की दृष्टि हो गई है
उसको आप राजी होकर के क्या दोगे? इसलिए वो कृपालु देव ने कह दिया कि सुन प्रभु चरण
तने धरूं आत्मा थी सहुहीन ते तो प्रभु है आपे।
वर्तुं चरण आदि। मेरी ताकत। कर तो करना भी मेरी ताकत नहीं है कि मैं आपको कुछ
दे सकूं। देने लेने का कोई question ही नहीं है। इसीलिए इस दुनिया में
ऐसी दृष्टि होना कि इस दुनिया के अंदर मेरे
से बढ़िया भगवान भी नहीं है। मेरे से बढ़िया दुनिया में कोई मेरे से बढ़िया नहीं
है। इसने सौगानी जी के वचन देखे? वो compare किया है तराजू का बात।
कि एक तराजू के अंदर सारी दुनिया को रख दो। सारे भगवान को रख दो। क्या?
बड़े-बड़े हिमालय, मेरून पर्वत सब डाल दो इसके बाजू। पले-पले में।
और बाद में मैं आ जाता हूँ, इस side में। क्या होता है?
वजन किसका ज्यादा होगा? किसका वजन... किसका वजन ज्यादा है?
अब दुनिया का दुनिया में तो इतने भगवान इतने वो ये सब नीचे आ जाएगा कि वो कौन सा नीचे
क्या होगा position क्या होगी?
कि नहीं मेरा value ज्यादा है तो मैं नीचे और वो ऊपर आएंगे वो हल्के हैं
मैं भारी हूँ ऐसा होगा? बहुत अच्छा लिखा है।
फिर सौगानी जी के वचन की ताकत देखोगे तुम। कि पूरी दुनिया एक पल्ले में
रखता हूँ और दूसरे... पूरी दुनिया एक पल्ले
में रखता हूँ और दूसरे पल्ले में मैं आता हूँ।
तो जैसे मैं जाते ही वो सब उछल के बाहर गिर जाते हैं।
देखो कितनी value है।
अभी चौथे गुणस्थान में हैं।
स्त्री कुटुंब परिवार के बीच रहते हैं। दिन भर मारे मारे फिरते हैं
order के लिए, पैसे कमाने
के लिए। पूरी गृहस्थ द्वेष वाली दशा है।
लेकिन अंदर का power क्या है? इस दुनिया में मेरे से ऊँचा कोई नहीं है।
हे गुरुदेव आपके इन वचनों ने तो क्या कमाल कर दिया है।
ईश्वर की उत्तम उत्तम चीज़ मुझे दे दी है।
और मुझे यकीन नहीं आता है कि क्या मेरा मोक्ष होने वाला है। देखो
क्या सपना हुआ।
सपने में भी कभी नहीं सोचा वो चीज़ सामने
नज़र में आ रही है
कि वाह। वो चीज़ सामने नज़र में आ रही है कि वाह मैं भगवान बनने वाला।
भगवान बनने वाला क्या मैं हूँ भगवान।
कितनी ताकत और ऐसा भगवान कि दूसरा कोई भगवान मेरे से ज़्यादा ऊँचा नहीं है।
कैसा भगवान हूँ? ये इसका नाम है दृष्टि।
दृष्टि में सारी दुनिया की महिमा zero होती है। केवल अपनी ही महिमा रहती है।
अपनी अवस्था को भी नहीं गिनना है उसमें कि वो मैली है कि अच्छी है कैसी है। जो मैं
नहीं है कि अच्छी है कैसी है वो out boundary के बाहर।
अपने मैं मैं में तो वही चीज़ आएगी बिना अवस्था की चीज़।
ना उसमें राग द्वेष है ना उसमें वितरागता है। ना शुद्ध पर्याय है ना अशुद्ध पर्याय है।
कोई अवस्था उसमें नहीं है।
और हम जब भी चर्चा करते हैं mostly discussions छानबीन मार्गदर्शन तय कर लेते हैं। काय
का लेते हैं? अवस्था। जबकि रास्ता कोई दूसरा ही है,
सुखी होने का।
ये अवस्था का भूत इतना सवार है दिमाग के अंदर, कि वहां से निकल नहीं सकते हैं।
और ये साधना की रुकावट है। उसको बार-बार कहना पड़ता है कि भई वहां से हटो।
Investigation. Investigation में ऐसा
क्यों, ऐसा क्यों किया?
क्या किया तेरे में क्या बिगड़ा? भई देख अंदर में। या देख अंदर में।
तेरे परमात्मा को किसने गाली दी? किसने छुआ तक भी नहीं है।
दूसरा तो मारो गोली तेरी अवस्था ने तेरी आत्मा को नहीं छुआ है।
क्या काहे को उठा हुआ हो हल्ला काहे को मचाया इतना? तेरे में क्या कमी आ गई?
तेरे में कहाँ दाग पड़ा है? मान्यता में गड़बड़ है।
कि मैं उसने ऐसा कह दिया मैं जैसा नीचे हो गया। उसने गाली दी तो मैं नीचे हो गया।
तुम नीचे थे ही कब तुम तो हमेशा ऊँचे हो।
लेकिन तुम अपने पर्याय से अपने को मापते हो ना तो घड़ी में ऊँचे होते हो घड़ी में
नीचे हो जाते हो। तुम पर्याय के पार देख लेते हो आप स्वयं भगवान
हो। लेकिन कितना वो वाला मचाया है।
और फिर डायरी लिखना पड़ता है वो करना
सर्वभाव समभाव। पड़ता है वो करना सर्वभाव समर्पण क्या है?
और जो अपने परमात्मा की दृष्टि नहीं करते हैं, जिनकी साधना बराबर नहीं चलती है,
उसको diary लिखना पड़ता है ताकि उसकी साधना बराबर चलती रहे।
बाकी diary का कोई value नहीं है।
साधना अगर अच्छी चलती है तो बात क्या करना? छिपा लेना अपने आप को,
साधना अच्छी चल रही है। बोलने की जरूरत नहीं है कि मेरी साधना अच्छी चल रही है।
और कोई बोले कि नहीं आपकी साधना अच्छी नहीं चल रही है क्योंकि diary नहीं लिखते।
उनका अभिप्राय है। मेरी नज़र में मैं कौन हूँ?
मैं किसी से कम नहीं हूँ। मैं कुछ हूँ नहीं, मैं सब कुछ हूँ। क्या? हम भी कुछ हैं?
ऐसा छीना-झपड़ करके भैया तुम ही सब कुछ हो। कुछ क्या तुम ही परमात्मा हो।
लेकिन अपने को गिरा दिया, हम भी कुछ हैं तो
गिरा दिया। मैं ही सब... मैं ही सब कुछ हूँ तो ऊँचा रख दिया बराबर है ठीक।
तो दृष्टि में अपनी value करना अपुन सीखो अपने आप को। कि मैं किसी से कम नहीं हूँ।
यथार्थ में तो
उक्त अस्तित्व पने की अखंड दृष्टि के बल पर पर्यायों का क्रम सहज ही
अखंड की ओर बढ़ता रहता है। पुरुषार्थ आदि की इन पर्यायों में
कोई उलटफेर... कोई उलटफेर अधिक व कम पुरुषार्थ ऐसा करना नहीं पड़ता है।
क्या? थोड़ा speed बढ़ा दो, आज अच्छा
चला, कल भी ऐसा अच्छा कर दो, जल्दी-जल्दी आगे निकल जाओ। ना तुम अच्छा कर सकते हो,
ना कुछ बुरा कर सकते हो।
ना ज्यादा कर सकते हो, ना कम कर सकते हो। कुछ करना,
नहीं करना, तेरे हाथ की बात नहीं है। क्योंकि परमात्मा कुछ करता नहीं है।
कारण क्या? कारण क्या वजह है? कि क्योंकि कारण की पर्याय में तो मेरा,
यानी कि दृष्टि के विषय का अस्तित्व ही नहीं है।
मैं वहां हूं ही नहीं, कि मैं उसमें कुछ कर सकूं। मेरा अस्तित्व कहां है?
मेरा अस्तित्व तो त्रिकालीपन में है। पर्याय में
दृष्टि। अस्तित्व में। इससे पहले नहीं, पर्याय में। पर्याय में तो मेरा,
मेरा माने दृष्टि के विषय। पर्याय में तो मेरा
दृष्टि के विषय का अस्तित्व ही नहीं है। अब मैं बढ़ा के क्या करूँ घटा के क्या करूँ?
जहाँ मेरा कुछ लेना देना नहीं है वहाँ बढ़ा करके क्या करना है?
ये 2 माले का नहीं 4 माले का बनाओ लेकिन भैया 2 10 माले का बनाओ तेरे
को कुछ मिलने वाला नहीं है।
तेरा अस्तित्व वहाँ नहीं है। जिसको तुम बढ़ाना चाहते हो वो तेरा अस्तित्व नहीं है।
केवल ज्ञान हो जाएगा तो क्या होगा? कि तेरे में सुधार आएगा।
तो वही का वही रहोगे जो अभी हो ना वही का वही रहोगे।
केवल ज्ञान होने से तुमको
ना light नहीं हो जाएगी अंदर में?
केवल ज्ञान खुद के आत्मा के आगे। कि नहीं केवल ज्ञान हो जाएगा तो कड़वा था ना आत्मा तो
मीठा हो जाएगा। काला था तो
सफेद हो जाएगा white प्रकाश वाला हो जाएगा।
और अशांत था तो बहुत शांत हो जाएगा।
कि नहीं। तो बहुत
शांत हो जाएगा। नहीं वो अशांत नहीं है अभी नहीं, वर्तमान में ही नहीं।
तो केवल ज्ञान होने से और परमात्मा बनने से कोई फर्क नहीं पड़ेगा उसको। क्यों?
कि पर्याय में बढ़ोतरी हुई है उसमें तेरा अस्तित्व नहीं है तुझे
कुछ भी नहीं मिला commission। और जो
भी बढ़ना कम ज्यादा हुआ है वो सब अवस्था में हुआ है।
तू तो पहले से ही अवस्थाओं से पार है। ये दृष्टि रखिए।
पर्याय में तो मेरा माने दृष्टि
के विषय का। मेरा माने दृष्टि के विषय का अस्तित्व ही नहीं है कि
मैं उसमें कुछ कर सकूँ
क्योंकि मेरा अस्तित्व कहाँ है मेरा अस्तित्व तो त्रिकालीपन में है।
आशा है
मेरा दृष्टिकोण मैं व्यक्त कर सका हूँ।
प्रश्न पूछा था ना कैसे वृद्धि करता है?
शायद मैंने तो अपने हिसाब से लिख दिया शायद आपको समझ में आ गया होगा।
करना क्या है?
आगे बढ़ने के लिए क्या करना है? कुछ करना है। कह रहे हैं कि करना सो मरना है।
कुछ किया तो गलत। मतलब
जिसको लिखे अगला ज्ञानी है, महात्मा भी है, तो ही
वो समझ सकेगा ये चीज। बाकी तो वो समझ में भी नहीं आएगा। ये लगाने
का है, नहीं समझाऊंगा।
अपना क्या करना है? नहीं नहीं, सौगानी जी ने जिसको पत्र लिखा होगा।
वो ये इतनी गहराई में जाने
का तो ताकत नहीं है। ओ देखो
साक्षात गुरुदेव वहाँ बिराजते हैं उनको नहीं पूछ सकते हैं। एक देखने की बात है।
वो Calcutta बैठे हैं उनको letter लिख करके पूछते हैं वृद्धि कैसे करूँ।
इसका मतलब क्या? उसकी बुद्धि का तो दिवाला निकल ही गया है। कि जिनसे
सौगानी जी सीख के चले गए Calcutta।
उनको पूछना पड़ता है कि मैं वृद्धि कैसे करूँ।
साक्षात बैठे हैं गुरुदेव पूछो ना। कि वहां तो कांप जाते हैं वो।
क्योंकि अंदर में चोर बैठा है।
सब तो विद्वान का ही काम है। विद्वानों का ही
छानबीन करते हैं लेकिन उनको पले एक भी परसत नहीं पढ़ने वाला।
सौगानी ही कहां पहुंच गए। वो उनको पले कहां से पढ़ो। कितना गहराई है इसके अंदर।
पूरा मोक्ष मार्ग इसके अंदर है। अब बड़े-बड़े गाथाओं को क्या करोगे।
पूरे शास्त्रों का सार तो इधर आ गया।
तो आशा है मेरा दृष्टिकोण मैं व्यक्त कर सका हूं।
धर्मस्नेही निहालचंद। Dharmasnehi Nyalchand Sothan. Ye 5 lecture poore hue ek patra.